[Music]
thanks to lastpass for sponsoring a
portion of this video hey what's up guys
mkbhd here so a common opinion or
popular sentiment i've heard is that
foldables
are
a bit of a gimmick you know there's no
point to them why are they even trying
they shouldn't be made just stick with
regular phones
and i could see why you would think that
you know they really stumbled out of the
gate early in 2019 the two thousand
dollar re-released galaxy fold and the 2
400
delayed huawei mate x are kind of the
top two right now and then there's the
the royal flex pi which nobody should
buy but when a market starts to grow and
mature there become different ways to
differentiate yourself inside of it and
so now along comes lg and while they're
clearly not doing a folding display what
they are doing is doubling down on the
whole concept of a bigger screen that
can fit in your pocket thanks to being
foldable so that's why lg made this this
is the lg g8x
thin queue but i'm never gonna say that
whole name
and this phone costs 6.99 and for that
price it also comes with the dual screen
accessory
i'm gonna say that again the phone the
flagship phone and the dual screen
accessory together
included
700 bucks so you can just get the phone
by itself if you want to but honestly
there's not a whole lot of reason to
it's their new flagship but it's a
pretty unremarkable phone by itself in a
lot of ways they're sticking with the
risk-free plain jane design that they
have for a little while glass sandwich
that's a slight hint of blue color again
on the back
flat no camera bump for the standard and
ultra wide camera which is nice and then
a 6.4 inch flat 1080p oled 60hz display
nothing too crazy and then they moved
the optical fingerprint reader from the
back to underneath the display glass so
they've caught up to that 2019 trend
there's still a single speaker at the
bottom paired with the earpiece speaker
up at the top which is over a pretty
standard notch in 2019 it's better than
some but again in a world of hole
punches and pop-up cameras and wild
rotating mechanisms this is again the
safe route and the specs are pretty
plain too there's actually only one spec
snapdragon 855
six gigs of ram and 128 gigs of
expandable storage
it's ip68 certified
and a 4 000 milliamp hour battery that's
nice since we've seen some others
pixel uh mess this up uh but if they
keep the headphone jack which they have
and the quad dac for the die hards
they'll still be able to rock those
trusty wired headphones but overall i
can tell you no one's exactly drooling
over anything crazy about this design
it's not the design that's selling this
phone it's not the specs that are
selling this phone
this dual screen case though now that is
what's selling this phone so this is a
mostly plastic case not exactly built
like a tank but it's lightweight which
is important and it's made specifically
for this phone again and this new
version we have here has a usb type-c
port inside of it that plugs into the
phone and now everything in the case is
powered by the phone so the display on
the inside the buttons duplicated on the
side of the case it's all now connected
and lit up and there's a five pin
pass-through port at the bottom and it
comes with a usb type-c adapter so if
you want to charge with the case on you
simply just connect that adapter with
some magnets with
with the magnets oh wow this is the best
part of the case i love these magnets
okay so you can connect and charge up
with the adapter thanks to
the magnets love that anyway then you're
in then you have this entire second
screen you have this 360 degree hinge
that you can fold back and away when you
don't want to use it
and lg's really double down on the
functionality
and the software features of making this
better than the previous version
maybe to a fault like right off the bat
i'll acknowledge it straight from the
top one of the pieces of feedback lg got
from the last one was that the color
temperature between the two screens
wasn't exactly perfectly the same and i
can vouch for that so the solution for
the g8x was to use the exact same
display panel for both the phone and the
case which means yes there is a notch at
the top of the case's display even
though there's nothing in it there's no
second camera no sensors nothing it's
literally just an empty cutout but it's
just another notch over there this is
one of those things i mean it's it's
symmetrical i guess that's cool but
that's gonna be one of those things
that's really easy to make fun of but
look the software features when you have
two screens instead of one folding
screen
have to acknowledge that there's a bezel
and kind of embrace it and take
advantage of it we've seen this before
so lg's dual screen software still does
all the same stuff that it could do last
year matches the brightness across the
displays lets you have different apps
open one on each side simultaneously you
can swap sides
but now there's more there's a three
finger gesture to move an app from one
screen to the other you just kind of
flip it over and it works pretty well
and there's also now wide mode enabled
for certain apps like in chrome for
example it spans across both displays
now again this is a little more rough
because that is a pretty chunky bezel in
between them but you know it kind of
looks like two phones taped together
next to each other but with continuity
between them honestly it's going to be
up to app developers to to make their
best apps take advantage of these dual
screens and foldable screens for that
matter
but it's still early days for everyone
trying to work on this stuff so i'm
trying not to be too harsh or judgy on
the app situation for foldables just yet
but it could use some work i think
possibly the most ambitious feature that
lg built in is called the gamepad which
turns one of your screens into a game
controller that lets you map specific
buttons on the controller to certain
touch areas on the screen in games you
play and it works okay in some suggested
games it's not great with the few games
that i play on my phone
but i like the ambition that's one of
the more forward thinking uses of dual
screens that i've seen in a while bravo
also there's a two inch preview screen
up at the front of this case that shows
the date and the time and battery and
some notification previews
i don't really use it much it's super
low refresh rate it seems like maybe
about 15 hertz
but you can turn it off if you don't
like it also that being said a couple
other quick quirks about this
why is the whole front of this case
glossy other than the little screen up
here there's no need to make this entire
thing
a fingerprint magnet and while it's cool
that wireless charging i can confirm
does work with the case on
why is this whole window here
cut out i mean other than the cameras
you don't really need anything
to to see through the logo is it because
you wanted to see the logo
that's kind of lame and on the battery 2
it is a 4 000 milliamp hour battery
which is nice for just the phone but i
haven't used this phone long enough to
tell if this will hold up powering both
screens for a reasonable amount of time
but i have been told it uses about 20
extra power through that usb type-c
cable powering both screens all the time
but look the whole point is this system
is lg's way of differentiating
themselves in this growing
segment
of foldables not necessarily folding
displays but folding devices
are coming galaxy fold folds out huawei
mate x folds in we have a rumored
motorola event coming up with possibly
refreshed razer that's a portrait
folding device folding screen kind of
the way flip phones were you have
microsoft's surface neo and surface duo
that are dual screen that are a 360
degree hinge and now you have lg coming
along with their much more budget
version also of a 360 degree hinge but
that's completely removable that you can
use like a regular phone when you want
to so that's it that's my thought that i
wanted to get out there that this first
generation of folding products like i
said it could be a folding screen or it
could just be a foldable in some way
is coming back
although
i guess if you had flip phones
it's sort of the second generation of
foldable products but you get the point
the apps have to come along everything
has to come along with it
but they're coming
and they're here to stay i believe it
let me know what you think in the
comment section below and until the next
one thanks for watching
see you guys later peace
thanks to lastpass for sponsoring a
portion of this video so how many
websites do you think you have logins
for you know probably all the social
media sites whatever the main ones are
that you use then you got your bank
website probably some fitness app you've
signed up for that you don't use that
much maybe your college email they're
starting to add up and if you don't have
unique credentials for each and every
single one of these sites then all it
takes is one of them to be compromised
and a bunch of them go down with it and
suddenly your personal information is
out there but remembering 20 different
passwords is also nearly impossible so
that is where lastpass comes in they
relieve the burden of having to remember
a ton of different passwords you can
keep all of your login information and
passwords and data safe in one place
conveniently and it's easy to use so you
can stay sane stop trying to reset
passwords and you forget them and try to
think about what the first constant you
ever went to was or what your high
school mascot was lastpass autofills
your credentials on these sites and on
mobile sites as well and there are apps
on ios and android so when you open an
app or a site lastpass will fill in your
username and password for you and make
it fast and easy to log in and they also
offer unlimited password storage and
free cross-device sync so even if you're
that guy that has to sign up for an
account on every website you visit and
you've got to have a unique password for
every single one because it's
technically the right thing to do
lastpass still got you covered so you
really just need to keep your one master
password safe and secure and that's the
last pass
you'll need to remember
see what i did there
last pass anyway
that's it thanks for watching